[Music]
well Britney Spears performed her iconic
hit baby one more time during her last
Vegas residency I mean how could she not
but her Sin City return is in the only
reason to celebrate because her breakout
hit is also turning 20 does it feel like
it's been 20 years it's been so fast you
know like I feel like I just started
yesterday 1998 a 16 year old Brittany
records the single after the Backstreet
Boys and TLC pass on the song it's
released at just a year and a half after
she and future boyfriend Justin
Timberlake leave the Mickey Mouse Club
her smash hit quickly sells over 10
million copies and sent Spears on her
first tour as JT's opening act I was
opening up for a coke cut in sync I got
lucky and we know we worked out great
that was 1999 our first sit-down with
Britney the same year she scored two
Grammy nominations for her debut album
how exciting is it for you to have such
a hot record right now I'm good good and
some really overwhelming right now the
video was already popular and it was all
Britney's idea I thought it would like
be really cool you know the kids dance
cool they filmed at a real high school
Speirs love interest in the video
marilla cousin chad the naughty
schoolgirl outfit well it's from Kmart
cost under $17 but barring her major
I've actually got some backlash from
parent associations so I'm just taking
that one day out of the day at a time
you know the video racked up three MTV
VMA nominations at the awards for years
before her headline making kids with
Madonna Britney was nervous to even be
near the Material Girl I was like
freaking out but I didn't get a chance
to meet her what would you tell that
Britney from 20 years ago I would tell
that Britney just to believe in yourself
and never doubt yourself this
entertainment business has not affected
me really at all I'm still the same
Britney totally
you